сьогодні день в парламенті просто б'є
всі рекорди по безпределу коли
пропозиції одних депутатів ставляться на
голосування майже такі пропозиції інших
депутатів не ставляться відбувається
сегрегація коли виймають гарні закони з
порядку денного не хочуть повертати коли
в порушення регламенту не ставлять
постанову про відкликання пані безуглої
з комітету питань нацбезпеки і от зараз
ще одне порушення тому що ми і це
відображено в стенограмі ми зайшли в
розгляд питання по повній процедурі і це
сказано там навіщо повертатися і навіщо
робити порушення за порушенням Давайте
припинимо сьогодні
реально беспредел в регламенті прошу іти
по повній процедуріку Дякую Артур
Володимирович Я хочу нагадати що саме
скорочена процедура була погоджена на
погодженій Раді